Oh what fools these mortals be I don't
know how fitting that one was but that's
that's my favorite Shakespeare quote you
know ever hey everybody
overdue Doctor Who review time and
before I get into it I've actually got a
sponsor for this one now before you
start scrolling through to get past this
part it's free because it's a podcast
this video is being sponsored by the
radio versus the Martians podcast which
if you have not checked it out is fun
insightful often very funny a Mike
Gillis and Casey Doran they talk about
anything pop culture related they talk
about Steven Spielberg Hayao Miyazaki
Star Trek Twin Peaks heck they had an
extended discussion on whether or not
people need to pull over for the
ghostbusters because you know flashing
lights siren do they uh-huh
but they talked about it so check them
out radio versus the Martians com+ you
know it's a podcast so whatever you used
to listen to podcast they'll be on there
Plus as a bonus they've also got their
running series where they do close
examinations of every single film Arnold
Schwarzenegger has ever made the best
and the worst high castle Avista baby
also part of radio versus the Martians
seriously check him out I'd been
listening to them for years well before
they got in touch with me to talk about
this so I'm happy to have them as a
sponsor moving along from there
yeah the Shakespeare Code so first
outing for Martha with the doctor and
it's sort of interesting in a few ways
in how especially in terms of how it
contrasts with rose because roses first
trip was to the far future Wow
into space technically just in orbit
around Earth but Martha's first trip
way back to the past to you know meet
the most famous British writer of all
time and this episode it's what I've
never really thought too much of I never
thought it was bad I was just kind of
yeah it's there um it's pretty good I
think I I don't know why I don't think I
gave credit for the performance of the
guy who's actually playing Shakespeare I
don't think I gave him his due on
previous watches you didn't Bowl me over
but he's good and he's charismatic and
he came when he goes for thoughtful
moments I buy it which you kind of need
for this I know some people because it's
come up in the comments actually
surprisingly recently I know some people
dig the carrionites and you know the
witches I have mixed feelings about them
part of it is because well it fits into
the whole thing that tends to bug me
about most Doctor Who historical set
episodes which is oh look at this this
your well-known mythological
supernatural phenomenon oh it's aliens
like a that trope within Doctor Who
irritates me because you know
potentially it has the interesting angle
of this is where our legends of these
things come from but it very very rarely
goes for that and instead just presents
us with just exactly what the thing
appears to be and it's obviously not the
source of the myth because like all the
people from that time are already
thinking oh my god it's this thing that
we already believe exists and this alien
just absolutely happens to line up with
all the tropes and beliefs that we have
about this mythological like it's lazy I
just I just don't really care for it
like about the one time I think it kind
of worked with was the beast with the
idea that the Beast may have been the
origin for the very concept at least the
visual elements of the devil like that
cool that was vague enough and far
reaching back enough that that worked
but something like oh well there's these
aliens that
like old crones with you so far and they
they do what looks like magic but it's
really technology I'm like okay that's
fairly standard for sci-fi anything
that's highly technological enough will
look like magic to those who don't know
yeah except the magic isn't controlled
by math or actual physical the the
pieces of Technology it's it's words
they speak words and amazing things
happen but we're gonna emphasize that
it's not magic plus one of them rides a
bro yeah I know some people can roll
with this some people find it fun some
people who like get into the sort of the
silliness of it and that's fine it just
it doesn't work for me it almost never
works for me and it doesn't really here
so the the carrionites
while I don't think the worst example of
this kind of thing because they have a
few saving graces I do think some of the
stuff done with the dolls and the puppet
are actually visually pretty well
realized in terms of looking at creepy
and unsettling so I I think that does
help a little bit it does take you know
sort of the curse off it a little bit
but conceptually I still don't love it
like I just I don't and I won't so I I
have to move past that part of it I do
like sort of Martha you know trying to
wrap her head around what's going on and
and I like they get a pretty good
balance with her sort of maintaining her
modern sensibilities and sort of
standing up for them but not to the
point of coming off like a jackass
because when you've got you know a
modern character in a historical time
who kind of scoffs that the way things
are there you know the idea of that a
woman doctor is unusual or that she
would need to be you know married to a
man or that shit's fine for Shakespeare
to flirt and have an affair even though
he's got a wife back at home and you
know nobody blinks an eye and and it's
possible when presented with things like
that for characters just to come off
like why are you even traveling in time
if you're just gonna go
well this is just silly and she doesn't
go that far but it does still establish
that she's a very strong-willed person
and is prepared to stand by what she
thinks is proper and I think they
balanced that pretty well given that it
could have gone off the rails fairly
easily I don't love the scene between
Martha and the doctor in the bed at the
end what I don't like about that is like
as a concept in and of itself it's fine
because it it can be it can start as a
seed towards you know the developing
feelings Martha has for him while at the
same time he's trying to undercut that
at every step but I don't love this
there's this one shot just one lingering
shot of her just kind of gazing at him
and I'm like not too soon can we build
to that like oh god it's did it one of
the things I really like about Martha is
spoiler the way she is it the show is by
going I'm never gonna get out of this
relationship while I want to so I'm
gonna choose to leave and for me that
strength gets at least slightly undercut
if she's appears to be falling this hard
this fast for this guy I wish they would
have pasted that better spread it out
over a couple more episodes instead of
dropping something that freaking obvious
you know first time out with him that
said as much as I have repeatedly said
how much I don't like the romantic angle
of the doctor companion relationship I
do appreciate that this actually works
pretty well as a comparative to a
rebound relationship you know the doctor
shouldn't really be getting into this
relationship he knows that which is why
he keeps saying you know you're not
replacing rose this isn't anything like
that yet even as he gets started in
something that is very much intended to
fill the void that the loss of Rose left
and I do think that is an interesting
enough dynamic and different from what
other dynamics have happened at least up
to that point in Doctor Who that
it's it's well played I don't on
principle I kind of don't love it but it
is actually nuanced enough to not just
feel like here's the new love interest
it does because he like oftentimes on a
TV show even something where it doesn't
have a dynamic like the doctor companion
that in my mind shouldn't be romantic in
the first place
even when they are playing it straight
it's pretty rare for a show to
understand properly this well like what
it's like to try and be with someone
else after you know a really hard loss
like often times on other shows it'll be
like one bad the one episode with one
bad date
you know after after a hard breakup or
whatever and then after that they
introduced the new love interest and
everything's fine and this feels like a
more thoughtful sort of look at that
element of relationships again in a
roundabout way because the doctor
companion relation dynamic is strictly
speaking not really dating although the
show kind of treats that like it and
yeah I hopefully people get what I'm
saying with that so the that whole
element it's in it honestly kind of
bothering me less now than it would have
back when I first watched it because I
think I was kind of like why do we have
to have this kind of crush thing going
on again and I still feel that but like
knowing that that's going to annoy me
I'm looking for is there still validity
to the way this this relationship is
being depicted and I think there is I
think there's there's something there
that is interesting and and just
different enough to not feel super
repetitive yet well down the road we'll
get to how frequently the doctor and the
companion becomes like a weird forced
romantic issue thing but yeah
Shakespeare cook for them I mean like
I'm also kind of a sucker for
Shakespeare
I like Shakespeare in general when I
went to to London yeah went to the Globe
Theater it was yeah it's it I do is sort
of enjoy that stuff so I'm a little bit
of a sucker for it while I'm I don't
love this episode by any means I do
considered to be one of the better
historical set episodes of modern who as
I tend to not like most of those
especially when they feature a famous
historical figure this is one of the
better ones I think oh also it's worth
noting the music in this for the
carrionites swarm you know during the
climax is really I mean I'm Murray gold
does good music anyway that's honestly
one of the one of the highlight pieces
for a villain that never returns they
get a really good really intense music
it's a great track yeah I think I'll
just I'll just wrap it up on that one
the Shakespeare Code it's a solid enough
start it's a decent enough follow up to
a strong introduction for Martha it's
not like taking it to the next level but
it's also not nose-diving it so I was
like okay cool
so that wraps up this one folks the
Shakespeare Code what do you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it buttons links patreon P o
box radio versus the Martians give them
a listen seriously it is actually a
really great podcast and because it's a
podcast it's free so all that stuff
check it out there'll be a link for our
radio version of the verses down in the
description along with everything else
give it a click or you know what it's
okay if you don't because at the end of
the day I'm not gonna tell you what to
do because you're the council I just run
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]